nous sommes toujours à sotchi qui
s'apprête à accueillir le monde
on le sait ces jeux sont pour vladimir
poutine l'occasion d'exhiber la grandeur
la puissance retrouvée de la russie ce
soir nous avons choisi de vous faire
entendre une voix qui s'élèvent contre
ce paris de vladimir poutine
celle de gary kasparov qui est considéré
comme l'un des plus grands joueurs
d'échecs de tous les temps comme
plusieurs autres opposants au président
russe garry kasparov a choisi de
s'exiler aux états unis par crainte de
représailles
je les rencontrer chez lui à new york
il a souvent été au coeur des
manifestations contre vladimir poutine
une des figures emblématiques de
l'opposition contre le régime russe
chedal qui dois-je vous répéter ce que
jeff keay hâtive que ce qui empêche une
révolution pacifique rendent inévitable
une révolution violent
garry kasparov est un ancien champion
d'échecs un des plus grands de
l'histoire il est resté pendant 15 ans
le numéro un mondial depuis 2005 qui
joue sur l'échiquier politique
l'enjeu qui lui tient à coeur défendre
les droits et libertés
j'ai toujours dit que mon engagement
politique pour la défense des droits de
la personne avec un but d'empêcher une
transition révolutionnaire sans relâche
hydraulic août
j'ai fait ce que j'ai pu avec ma modeste
influence sur les événements mais il
semble évident que poutine ne poudre à
rester au pouvoir pour le reste de ses
jours tous deux décroché niçois doctrine
faudra voir si la nouvelle génération
avec des opinions différentes pourra le
tolérer cinq ou dix ans face à nada
garry kasparov entreprenante des années
d'organiser un mouvement d'opposition à
vladimir poutine
il se présente même contre lui aux
présidentielles mais sans succès en 2012
il est arrêté et brièvement emprisonné
la réélection de poutine met fin à ses
aspirations
ne parlons pas d'élection personnes
étaient venues à vis une comédie
n'utilisez pas ce mot n'insultez pas mon
intelligence une élection veut dire que
vous avez un parti d'opposition parti
inscrits que vous avez la liberté de
presse etc les gens ont accès à la
télévision est un processus qui permet
aux gens d'avoir des opinions
différentes des partis politiques qui
puissent se défier le candidat sortant
tout cela n'existe pas en russie
vous ne pouvez pas vous inscrire dans le
système politique
à moins d'être fidèle à 100% au registre
maintenant en voyant les jeux de sotchi
arriver à grands pas le bouillant joueur
d'échecs ne mâche pas ses mots envers la
mégalomanie du président russe dans tout
ça c'est le projet d'un dictateur il
faut vraiment faire des efforts pour
trouver un seul endroit en russie ce qui
n'est pas de neige en hiver
sotchi est un titre en effet et la
température moyenne est de 10 degrés
celsius
la ville ne peut pas supporter de telles
infrastructures
après les jeux ils deviendront des
ruines des cyclones tropicaux des
proches of keeping discussion elle
fonctionne le bio loin imagination qui
l'entretient seront faramineux il avait
le souci ne pourra pas se le permettre
on parle de jeux qui ont coûté selon des
chiffres officiels le poutine 50
milliards de dollars
monde infesté de zombies news drugs
c'est de la folie
506 et je me font penser à ceux de
berlin en 1936 et à l'exception que ceux
de berlin était organisée de façon
impeccable mais chaque fois qu'on fait
cette comparaison est qu'on mentionne le
nom d'hitler
les gens ont peur parce que c'est le mal
absolu
en 1936 le régime au pouvoir étaient
légitimes et les restrictions à la
liberté de presse comparable à celle
d'aujourd'hui en russie
bien sûr il ya eu les nazis en 1939 41
mais parlons de 1936 une hausse de 1,8
ou faux je me fous complètement de ce
que pensent les canadiens mes amis sont
maintenant tous en prison des clippers
henry wendat et tous vos kilos réseau as
far as tu bien sûr n'oubliez pas qu'il
peut faire encore plus de mal que
n'importe qui en appuyant sur le bouton
ou chaude et l'air n'avait encore rien
fait en 1936 poutine a déjà envahi la
géorgie en 1936 qui est allemand était
légitime lisez les journaux russes garry
kasparov dénonce aussi le retour de la
russie comme joueur incontournable sur
la scène internationale
selon lui vladimir poutine a su profiter
de la faiblesse de l'occident au risque
de bouleverser les équilibres de la
planète à 10h à 12h gender assure à des
gender de free world de notre campagne
quand vous regardez les objectifs de
poti l'issue du monde libre ils ne sont
pas compétents ce vote il a besoin d'un
prix du pétrole élevés si ces prix
baissent
il fait faillite parce qu'il a besoin de
liquidités la seule façon de garder tout
le monde à ses pieds et leur donner des
cadeaux
spike jones à annezin chao awa et donc
est bien la seule façon de garder les
prix du pétrole élevés c'est d'avoir des
conflits au moyen-orient
bien entendu et qu'il a tué les iraniens
aussi c'est une situation gagnante pour
tout le monde
il ya de l'argent en leur vendant des
armes c'est d'un point de vue
psychologique c'est important bachar al
assad
ce sera un agitateur de moins et il ya
déjà beaucoup de signataires qui ont été
renversés
ce tout mais l'éditeur a dit abou
garry kasparov a jugé plus prudent de
quitter la russie
il vit maintenant ici à new york mais il
refuse de se taire
à new york je fais ce que je peux
modestement je suis père de famille est
bien occupée mais je critique à voix
haute
vous m'entendrez beaucoup plus ici qu'à
moscou agonie